hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
match between paul charles murphy and
daniel harvitz uh as you know uh they've
already played quite a few games uh and
the harvest is constantly backing out
from the match he's
constantly asking for more time and then
he says okay next time we're
we continued then no more uh taking
breaks no more uh pauses between the
games
but again he took a break and morphy
again has to
has to deal with it so while morphy's
been waiting for him uh he's been also
uh enjoying some some games in the cafe
de la regions
but in all this time harvest has also
been playing games regardless of
him not meeting morphy uh in the uh
agreed time
so here after a few days have passed i
think this game was played on the
fourth of october uh harvest um uh
said that uh he's feeling okay now and
that he would like to continue the match
with mr morphy so the score is currently
four uh in favor of morphe 2 in favor of
harvest
uh and this is the well uh one of the
one of the later games that we'll be
showing now so
uh let's check it out morphe has the
white pieces uh and he opens with uh
sorry about e4
already being on the board and he opens
with e4
uh we have e5 by harvest knight to f3 we
have d6
and now d4 striking in the center so the
philidor's defense is on the board we
have bishop to g4
and this is now a setup of uh well quite
a famous
paul morphy game that i'm sure most of
you know uh morphe continues with the d
captures on e5 and now of course the
pawn cannot be captured because then we
trade queens and then we also grab this
pawn attacking f7 and the bishop
and here white is already much better
you have to go back with the bishop to
prevent both threats
and then white just continues playing
the game the position is better he's up
upon
probably a win for morphy so instead
you can't capture back right away you
have to first eliminate the knight with
bishop captures queen captures
and now the captures on e5 so the
material uh
has been uh equally exchanged we have
bishop to c4
morphy develops the bishop while
threatening checkmate here and now
knight to f6 this is how harvard's
defense and now
queen to b3 attacking the f7 pawn as
well as the pawn on b7 so how do you
prevent all of this
well like i said there is a very famous
game that morphe uh played against
two very uh famous gentlemen where uh
they continued queen to e7
uh with the idea that if uh the queen if
the pawn is captured with queen to b7
then queen to be for
chuck will be used to trade queens uh
more if you didn't continue knight to c3
and you all know this game
uh the the the very famous one
uh but here we have bishop to d6 instead
and now he says okay you're more than
welcome to
to grab the pawn on b7 uh but the the f7
pawn is now also free for grabs so this
is what morphe goes for he goes bishop
captures an f7 with
check kings at f8 and now bishop to g5
developing with while pinning the knight
here
knight beat the d7 and now bishop to h5
we reach the position from the thumbnail
and the mate is being threatened here
uh so what do you what do you play here
the bishop cannot be captured
uh as the bishop captures queen would
occur so g6 here
defending against mate pushing the
bishop back and now
bishop to h6 check and it is as of movie
11 that this position has never been uh
reached again so let's see how our good
friend harvest deals with this he goes
king to e7
and now bishop back to f3 we have knight
to c5 now attacking the queen and also
defending the b7 pawn
and queen to c for now and here just b5
offering a pawn
and should morphy accept this then we
play rook to b8 we kick away the queen
and we have a nice semi-open b-file for
a rook while morphy's king is still on
e1
on castle so morphy says nope i'm not in
a hurry to grab any pawns i'm just going
to go back queen to e2
and now knight to e6 and even though
morphy
is up opponent he prevented the black
from castling uh the king is uh
uh well he's actually quite safe on e7
it's a it's a better position for white
uh make no mistake but uh let's uh you
know
this is a for for a position that
occurred in 1858
this is playable for black so bishop
back to e3 by morphe
and now a6 defending the b5 pawn we have
knight to d2 now preparing the castle
queen side
and the king to f7 uh we have castle's
queen side by morphe now the rook is
aligned with the queen so you have to be
careful about that
so queen to e7 and now g3 by morphe
morphe really slow playing this he wants
to move the bishop he wants to
get the rook into the game push f4 bust
open the f file and then
use the a file to attack the black king
so we have rook h the b8 harvest now
with rook's position
on the a and b file he would like to
push those pawns and create some threats
um
on the queen side like we said so bishop
g2 morphy
still preparing to push that f pawn and
now a5
both players now uh start pushing on the
uh their respective sides of the board
we have rook h to f1 morphe still
prepares it morphy
really really slow playing this with a4
and now
finally f4 ready to open up the f file
we have
a3 and morphe of course plays b3 doesn't
allow
uh a captures on b2 to open up the a
file for the rook
so king to g7 sdf file is about to open
up and now
f5 by morphe attacking the knight and
the
well the g6 pawn can be captured at any
moment
and now knights to f8 the knight down
nicely defends the g6 spawn
and uh here harvest is saying okay i
just want to stop your advancement on
the king side and continue my
advancement on the queen side
so morphe continues with g4 and now
queen to e8 uh you have to get uh get
the queen out of the way otherwise
g5 and f6 are coming so queen to e8 was
played
and here uh morphe not in a rush you
could play g5 for example knight h5 f6
and this is all uh very
very nice uh but after king to h8 it's
still
uh there there's still nothing immediate
to end the game and the morphe is always
looking for things like that so here
morphe just plays bishop to f3 first
that will come in handy
later on in the game between the c6 by
harvest and
now knight to b1 you have to guard the
c3 square if you if you just
rush it with something like g5 then
queen to c3
and harvest wins there's no way to
prevent
a loss here you could try something like
knight b1 to free up this square for the
king but it doesn't help like
check king here you're gonna deliver
check with the bishop uh you cannot push
c3
due to the pin you have to go back and
then we just play queen captures and
after this this is just checkmate now
the bishop covers this square
so a morphe has to be careful here or
you have to you know
make sure that everything is safe on
your own side of the board and only then
continue pushing pawns on the other side
where you're the one who's attacking
so knight b1 defending the c3 square and
now
b4 uh we have queen to f2 by morphe
uh and now from from f2 morph we will be
able to lift the queen with queen to h4
and if needed
the queen can you know wreak havoc along
the
h file so knight eight the d7
and now comes finally g5 so the knight
now has to move knight g8 and now
f6 with check and here king to h8
uh you could also try something like
king to f7 but here you just
allow queen h4 and there is really
nothing you can do there
it's just a terrible terrible position
if you play knight f8 to guard this pawn
then just bishop the e2
and again this is uh this is really
unplayable the bishop is coming to c4
and it's just going to be very very hard
to play this
very quickly black will uh lose this
terribly
so instead after f6 check we have king
the h8 by harvest but now
f7 by morphe and now morphy says uh you
really don't have a good move because if
you move the knight
for example knight to e7 then i play
bishop to g4
and there's no defense here i'm
threatening to pick up the knight
the knight is the only piece covering
the f6 square if queen to f6 comes
that's a game
uh for example if rook f8 we're just
going to capture it captures captures
and queen f6 is checkmate so
uh very very few uh options here
left for harvest harvest plays knight to
c5 he offers the knight here
uh but morphy says yeah that that will
not help you so just f captures and g8
uh queening
uh this comes with czech king captures
and now bishop catches on c5 with bishop
captures and queen e2
and now this is the position morphe is
up a piece but still okay
harvest does have some have some sort of
an attack going on on the queen
side uh morphy needs to keep this knight
here to prevent any sort of checkmating
ideas so
maybe it's not like morphe's up a piece
maybe the
the material is actually equal
as morphe is unable to activate his
knight also
harvest things so here we have queen the
e6
but now just knight to d2 the knight is
now activated
we have king to h8 and now bishop to g
for grabbing more space here we have
queen to e7
and now knight to f3 so morphy not
really in a worry
about those dark squares on the queen
side we have rook to d8
offering a rook trade and now h4 morphe
continues pushing here
now the knight can move the g5 upon is
also
very well defended we've rooked the d6
harvest ready to double up on the d
file and now rook captures morphe of
course doesn't allow that we have c
captures and queen to c for now and you
can see how morphy is uh
controlling these light squares uh so
nothing can
cross this yes this bishop is uh not
really doing anything it's it's pretty
much a pawn here and how are you getting
the rook into the game
uh well rook to faded this is one
attempt to this is what harvard's tried
but now queen to e6 morphe is still up a
piece and he wants to trade queens
uh we have bishop to e3 with check king
to d1
and now queen to c7 avoiding a queen
trade still trying to get that queen
into the
uh some sort of a meeting net but morphe
stops this uh entirely
knight to d2 now queen to c3 is of
course met with rook captures on fa to
check so
that's out of the question so bishop to
f4 was played closing up the f-file but
not
knight to c4 and you are never getting
your queen into
into the attack uh we have queen to c5
still trying but now just queen to d5
and now there are no squares all of
these squares are covered by
uh either or white's uh uh pieces
uh or yeah covered by white's pieces and
there's
really nothing to to be done here you
could move the
the queen uh but then you control
really no squares so here queen captures
on d5 was played by harvest
e captures on e5 and now rook to d8
guarding the pawn here but now it's an
end game where morphy's just a clear
pawn up
and for him that is more than enough
rook to have three
king to g7 we have c3 here uh destroying
this
uh structure on the queen side rook to
b8 and
now c captures on b4 we have rook
captures and
now just king to c2 bringing the king
into the game
king to f8 now king c3 the rook has to
go back
rook b5 attacks the pawn here just the
bishop to e6
and there is nothing for black to play
here there are no weaknesses in this
position this is just terrible
uh so this pawn is hanging you have to
defend it somehow so rook the c5 just
pins the knight but now
b4 uh we rook to c7 now b5
morphe is controlling d square so it's
not a problem
king the e7 with b6 attacking the rook
rook the b7
and now bishop the c8 attacking the rook
pushing the rook back rook b8 and now
b7 and now what do you play here king d7
was played
now comes knight captures on d6 there
was really nothing better for black here
king is seven knight to b5 now now
getting ready to push the other pawn as
well
here h6 was played but morphe just
played d6 check
and it was in this position on move 59
that daniel harvest resigned in the game
and the score now stands five to two in
morphy's favor
so after those two wins by daniel
harvick's uh morphe's uh
statement was correct as he said that
harvitz will not win a single game
anymore
uh so really uh amazing stuff and if you
remember we mentioned that um
uh the winner of the match is the first
one to reach seven victories and morphe
only reached five
but harvest nevertheless resigned the
entire match he was not interested in
playing this match anymore
uh and uh well he said that he resigned
on account of ill health
so there's also that but you know you
never know as
he constantly complained about being ill
about not being able to play
and then he was playing uh well every
day in cafe de la regence uh
without accepting morphy's challenge so
uh in the end
harvest resigned which was a problem
because harvest had a lot of backers
the prize money was was very i was well
was steeped to say the least it was a
prize fund of 295 francs
now i don't know how much uh that would
be today if any of you guys uh
are willing to maybe uh break it down
for us what 295 francs maybe in 1858
would be worth the day
probably you know there are different
ways okay if you invested it it would be
a whole lot if you just kept it you know
it would be
probably not that big of a difference
maybe if you i don't know
maybe if you just kept it and now maybe
sold it as a as a collector's item maybe
you'd get more but i don't know i've
been searching around
the internet a little bit and 295 francs
would be i don't know i i guess
somewhere between 5 000 and 10 000
today so it's pretty pretty a lot it is
it is said that in those days uh very
few people
uh reached the the amount of 100 francs
in their entire lifetime and this was a
one match for almost
300 francs uh so that being said that
that was uh
uh an insane amount and morphe of course
declined the money he did not want to
receive the money which was
a problem because uh for them to satisfy
everyone and for
everyone to receive their fair share
murphy had to
accept it and they would not hear any of
that
uh of morphy not accepting his share of
the money so morphe indian had to accept
it
uh but he not only accepted it he also
used a fair amount of that
to pay uh for a trip for adolf anderson
to come to paris and
meet morphy there uh well while morphy
was in paris
uh this is a part from uh lawson's books
i'm just going to read it to you
morphy immediately deposited the amount
uh with mr de illinois a proprietor of
the cafe de la reghans and had a notice
uh posted that any of the subscribers to
the stakes
were at liberty to withdraw the amount
to their subscriptions
the balance to be forwarded to adolf
anderson
at the freight expenses for his expected
trip to paris and his contest with mr
morphy
so more if you wanted to uh you know pay
pay for his trip
so very gentlemanly of morphe he was not
in it for the money he really just
wanted to crush
everyone that's how uh what kind of a
guy morphy was
and uh interestingly uh okay morphina
won the match and
even though uh harvest backers did not
uh feel that
that was okay because he still had uh
morphe still had two more games to win
before the match was ended
uh harvest then said okay let's let's
continue the match but morphy said no
you already resigned this
match we're not playing this match
anymore but if you're interested i'm uh
more than interested to play yet another
match and then
harvest declined he was not interested
in yet another match
but uh okay morphe we're gonna
continue this story uh in the next video
of the morphe saga but suffice it to say
uh morphe again fell a little bit ill so
he couldn't really
uh join them when uh adolf henderson uh
visited paris uh
at first and uh while morphy was sick uh
daniel
harvitz uh organized a blindfold
simultaneous exhibition where he also
faced eight opponents like morphe did
and uh
he won the simultaneous exhibition of
course but uh
it is said that uh you know strange
things happened in
in that simultaneous exhibition that
people just blundered pieces out of
nowhere
and harvests uh just you know uh
collected all of them it was like
i i mean i don't want to say it but it
was like uh they
organized everything up front that
harvest knew the moves that
they were going to play and
interestingly harvest
was one of the people that
was leading a chess column called monday
lustre
and it was not the games from the
simultaneous exhibition were not even
published
in that um you know chess column
and they were not published anywhere
else harvest did not want to allow those
games to be published
published so we don't we do not have
access to those games
uh but yeah very interesting stuff and a
very interesting
character this daniel harvitz but yeah
more if you won the game
more if you won the match and we are
continuing uh with uh you know who knows
what else might happen on this trip uh
in the next video of the paul morphy
saga
uh so uh that's the game uh ended the
match hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank uh stephen mccann
scott melis sebastian beaucher uh
joel abram and bruce cotman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day